well I understand that you were
responsible for acquiring South Park
yeah is that right how was that received
in Japan that was so tough because of
the translation okay and then the
characters fork too fast to understand
and then so it was so difficult to
create a Japanese stopped purging and we
followed the same way the u.s. creator
did so we recorded each by each from the
different voice actor and then we fast
for that and because their timing it's
so short and and then I believed we did
we did make the great Japanese version
and yeah I really enjoyed it actually
that program changed my professional
thing way of thinking oh how so because
luckily I could have a chance to meet
creators director a Parker and Matt
Stone because trades roommate was
Japanese Kai and then he introduced me
to him and to have a dinner with them
and then he once he invited me to his
private house and so I could feel the
atmosphere of the sauce park and I want
to convey that feeling to their Japanese
viewers as well and I started create our
original content to introduce the sauce
park and maybe that's the first step to
producing my original problem it's very
short term because of the promotional
content but I really enjoyed it so let
me see if I understand this so the
actors repeated word-for-word they went
in and did
ADR or new voiceovers yeah yeah so we'd
have to create Japanese version really
not the subtitle subtitle is too long
for the Salzburg because he speaks so
fast and then especially the first
program is the translation is so
difficult because they are talking about
American culture so they we have to
change a little bit to make our viewers
understand what they mean exactly
and then we but still their sentence is
too long to fit those lengths after they
did the first horded as well there Trey
and Matt did their all characters voice
and so and then they first of all a
little bit after they recorded so we
heard about that way of their recording
so I followed their way to do it
so normally only for 30 minutes
animation it takes maybe 2 hours to have
the recording but the South Park we took
like 5 or 6 hours and yeah as already
dressed for every 30 minutes yeah oh my
gosh Wow yeah so if I we make the 2
episode one day we just did like 12
hours straight and let's made me crazy
but it was really fun
how did the humor stand up yeah that's
their most difficult point so we change
a little bit and put their Japanese
culture taste and yeah but that
sometimes during the recording their
character the voice actors already
familiar with the character so they try
to change a little bit by themselves and
then we
you know whenever we hear it we you know
check their quality and and then the
meaning so that's a very creative point
of you know I really enjoyed it so did
you get letters from your audience
either for or against it and and what
was the what was the positive feedback
yeah
so this house part already has their
certain fans so they'll watch South Park
in English and maybe the mark marketing
target is not the majority I mean not
their white when children but their
certain percentage after our subscriber
they really loved that program Wow and
but to be honest was it it was so
difficult to keep broadcasting it
because of their you know they're not
accepted the majority holder viewers so
I tried the Caped program but after over
five years or seven years week okay
because the South Park is still
broadcast they're here in the United
States but they're we we don't carry it
anymore
do you think that was the subject matter
I was offensive via their character it
looks so cute as well except that in
Japan sure we prefer to have their
lounge character okay so yeah that's the
very interesting point like Shrek never
succeeded in Japan
it's loud but there it is I agree to
Japanese I think I love it
personally but they're not well accepted
you